Here is a story about a language that can create incredibly long words
and why he was alone in Europe, surrounded by languages ​​that work so differently.
Central Europe - many peoples with ragged borders.
But, let me show you a language card.
What do you see?
Probably more pieces.
Shortly German, some Romance, Slavic languages.
And this piece here - Hungarian
Now look again at the language family map.
The Hungarian piece is a language island surrounded by all Indo-European countries!
After learning about this isolation and calculating how many Hungarian words there are,
I just had to try 'magyar nyelv', the Hungarian language, for myself.
But, I'm not a Hungarian.
Practice with me and fix me, but this story is too good to not share.
Go back 1122 years, until the Pannonian lowland, flat, without the sea and
surrounded by mountains, she argued for her
And who better to end the disputes of tribes of nomadic horsemen that the Europeans called
, but they themselves were called by the name of their most important tribe
Led by Arpad,
The Magyars conquered the valley in 894
honfoglalás (founding)
To lash, S is y, and here's how you write with
but do not exchange or get them, Hungarian!
For the decades ahead, these masters of the bow and the horseshoe have established their authority
separating southern Slavs from other Slavs, and irritating peoples to Italy, France and Spain.
It is said that they had westerners on their knees, praying:
Arpad's successors managed to improve relations with the West.
Just to the Millennium, Stefan I founded the European Kingdom
a surprising victory for Christianity.
But success has isolated the Hungarian.
And by the end of this story, this language with its terribly long words will show how isolated the Hungarian is, and it is not.
Do you remember my adventure for the longest word?
These languages ​​extended words by taking a basic word and combining it with another base.
For example, there are two Buddha and Pest cities, uniting and having one name!
But that's not the reason why the Hungarian has such long words.
There are base words to which grammatical suffixes are added, especially at the end.
Suffocation for everything, I swear!
The verb '' jelent '' means reporting or reporting.
It's only made of smaller pieces, but anyway.
Let it be easy.
We put the prefix '' be- '' and the action is internal
Add the recurring suffix
And you are reporting yourself.
Also change the
A, and do not forget the suffixes for times and ways, for example about the potential -ne- (would)
There are millions of forms that shame even the Latin
Example ember (human)
For example, you want to give something to this man.
You will need the due date:
If there are several people, they are:
And if there is anything for them all:
Forget those scary-sounding maturities
They are just forms to DO, RETURN TO, ENTRY IN, EXIT FROM
and so on.
Same for adjectives.
Nagy means "great," but let's add something:
it means "like-great" wonderful.
Using the same suffixes, you can have many wonderful things and can save them for some wonderful:
or for many wonderful people:
Oh, there is more!
Example suffix for comparing wonderful things to find out what's more wonderful:
And a superlative prefix for the most wonderful:
Wait before you rest, more suffixes:
Do you now see why the Hungarian words can be so difficult?
These millions of roots and suffixes seem to be 'glued', so the linguists have called that kind of
creating words "agglutination" with the Latin root:
Some linguists are skeptical, but the concept is accepted
part of the glue supporting the Hungarian is the harmony with the vowels
Have you noticed all is, eh, eh?
These e-tags in the suffix are there to match the verb in the base
For this the set of ember is:
, but mouths are:
This is the initial Hungarian grammar, but is so foreign to his neighbors
But why?
We know where it is, but where did it come from?
The hint of his start is right in his words.
Historical linguists followed closely related words to Hungarian-like languages.
Nowhere near Hungary.
Far away, far ... in Western Siberia
Together with the Hungarian language, these languages ​​are part of the Ural language family.
The ancestors of the Hungarians migrated from Siberia to the southwest, carrying their longs
words on the threshold of the Pannonian Lowland, where our history began.
Hungarian, after all, you are not so alone.
Just your language relatives are far from you.
Stay and subscribe to languages!